okay okay fair enough that's that's
really good that's like very impressive
um i'm gonna read super chats for a
second you're gonna get all these people
in love with you
oh i can put up the chat oh yeah that's
great thank you can you just remind the
chat what the chat was okay guys so um
ish is going to show the sexual market
value chart and this is a chart made by
rolo tomasi basically showing
um
men and women's value in the dating
market
so yeah this is what we were talking
about earlier if you guys wanted to see
it
do you want to talk us through it before
we read super chats or just um no i mean
i don't know what else what are we
talking about do you guys agree with the
chart like you would say at 22 is most
girls peak
yeah
yeah at 12. so 22 most girls people okay
would you say would you 22 alone or
within that range roughly
okay
would you say you're left over by 35
yeah yeah yeah this is the most
geriatric
geriatric pregnancy is like 35 or 37. i
think it depends
so for example my dad met my stepdad so
she met him when she was like 34 35
and they basically had a great you could
say marriage like 13 years before he
passed away last year but he was
literally the top tier guy
mechanic earning all that good money but
also taking care of the family and yeah
so i think it could it just really
depends on the person but that's vegan
but that's more the minority rather than
majority so i understand that too so yes
we would say for the most for the most
part yeah i think if you're um
i think if you're talking strictly
physically attractive
then
yeah
for i think for most women then yeah
they're probably gonna you know their
highest their peak the season of their
peak is going to be in their early to
mid 20s but
i think any man who is looking for a
partner knows that a woman's value isn't
just in her looks
and so if he's going to choose her
there has to be more than that and i
think
just in my experience
that
while they can be very attractive women
who are 22 23
a lot of them don't have
they haven't developed the mindset to be
a good partner yeah
um so
yeah as long as she's attractive fine
but yeah if we're talking strictly
physically attractive then yeah of
course my question to you then is that
don't you think if you find a woman that
is willing to be submissive to you you
can train her in the way you'd like her
to think in a certain way because at
that moment when she's being submissive
to you she's putting all her trust in
you and at that moment if she's putting
a trust in you then she'd be able to
listen to the things you say
do the things that you'd ask her to do
without
little to no questioning and so you can
find a woman at a certain age that you
like with the beauty that maybe you
missed out on with another woman yeah
yeah and then get one i think i think
there can be an element of that but i
think there's and this is why i think
men or masculine feminine complement
each other there are things that women
bring that men just don't are not aware
of they don't they like they don't
expect do you know what i mean so a
woman who has that natural initiative to
um
to
be an asset to her man's life in ways
that he does he didn't even realize she
could i think that's something only
women can know if i'm being honest i
think there's an element of you can you
know guide her to be the kind of partner
you want if she's younger but
regarding the training i don't know
maybe in western countries
that's that's not very appliable
nowadays because if you go to university
and you go around asking them questions
about modern dating whatever
you're not going to find someone who's
very
appliable to train based on how these
how they view things and talk and
whatever so you're going to have a
difficult time with that so i wouldn't
go to a university looking for that
person
but most of them were there like 21 most
likely that's where you would find a
bunch of them that is true i think more
so than anything you kind of have to
understand that if you're looking to
date a certain type of person it's all
about strategic planning yeah you need
to position yourself in a situation
where you can find the type of woman
you're looking for now if the type of
woman i'm looking for and i'm not saying
i am personally no i'm saying if the
type of woman i'm looking for is someone
that um
is able to get on my page i probably
wouldn't go to university where
a lot of things are happening
um but it's just strategically where are
you positioning yourself to find the
type of woman you like or as a woman i
say to my sister are you positioning
yourself
in the positions yeah to find the type
of men you want um
okay i'm gonna read super chats for a
sec guys um if you have a comment that
you want read said send a super chat all
super chats are going towards studio
updates we want to get two more cameras
we talked about ish i think two yeah
they're talking cameras yeah two more
cameras i know we got issue camera you
guys are excited but we're gonna we're
trying to get two more just to get
better angles um on the people over
there like the far angle so whoever sits
there okay